now that you have a baby daughter do you
take a lot of pictures I take a crapload
of pictures but it's the digital age so
it's like you know my dad took I mean
hundreds of thousands of course but not
of us it was like we'd have these family
dinners and he would sort of you know
right when the digital cameras came out
you know it was also in perfect concert
with when the internet was dial-up so he
would take about a hundred thousand
photos and then at night he would get
online on the dial-up and email them to
everybody and you'd have it I'm not
joking here you'd have like four or five
hundred pictures of a blurry meatloaf
and it would take take you know the
gross domestic output of most countries
just to download all of these horrible
files and I remember I just I was a
terrible child let me preface it with
that I was about eighteen years old and
in the middle of the dinner once I I I
grabbed the camera and I went in the
bathroom and I just took a picture of my
penis and I just wanted to see if he
would naturally edit these photos at
some point nope yeah so I think there's
one day I hope it doesn't happen but I
there's a there's a penis picture of
mine floating around some well guess why
we found it
[Applause]
what do you think this is ma doesn't
mean I never I never saw her do people
who are like you know like sexting and
stuff and like send a picture of appeal
I can't think of anything more
threatening to send a woman than a
picture of a penis like in terms of like
sexy it's like just a rung below like a
picture of yourself
committing domestic terrorism I don't
know why someone does that I don't know
I've been told mine is not threatening
anybody yeah hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography